[Music]
what kind of scene needs to be shot 20
different ways a big action set piece
for thor love and thunder it was
something a little more emotional join
us as we figure out what scene was so
hard to get right and chase down what
else wound up on the cutting room floor
warning spoilers for thor love and
thunder ahead filmmaking can be
complicated sometimes what looks like a
simple shot that lasts just a few
seconds can take days weeks or months to
get right pick up shots will happen
months or weeks after a movie is wrapped
and reshoots can sometimes take place
weeks after a movie is otherwise in the
can movies that are technically
complicated and filled with
post-production work and cgi shots like
the latest mcu entry thor love and
thunder are sometimes broken down into
hundreds upon hundreds of different
shots there's a reason it takes months
for some films to make it to theaters
it's been an absolute disaster but
that's just the way it is on my films
between the retakes rewritten scenes
bits that end up on the cutting room
floor and the fact that sometimes
studios will demand reshoots there are
occasionally whole storylines that can
end up being lost in the editing process
in a recent interview with indie wire
actress natalie portman revealed that
director taika waititi shook one
particular moment in thor love and
thunder in 20 different ways indiewire
didn't say what scene it was possibly to
avoid spoilers but portman noted that it
was very emotional saying the
interesting thing was how we had room to
workshop them we filmed 20 different
versions of one key scene there's a few
pivotal emotional scenes but we did
really really different things many
different times it's quite possible that
she was referring to one emotional part
that involves portman's jane foster and
chris hemsworth thor breaking up quite a
reunion huh portman also described some
scenes that were deleted from the
movie's final cut the actress revealed
later in the interview that certain
scenes with tessa thompson's valkyrie
and jane which help explain jane and
valkyrie's friendship after jane picks
up thor's mantle weren't included
portman said there were whole sequences
planets characters and worlds that
didn't end up in the movie that were
hilarious and amazing and that we spent
a lot of time and energy on and
certainly the entire crew also designing
and conceiving
seems like a director's cut may be in
order while we don't know for certain
just how many scenes were cut from love
and thunder we do know that at one point
there was a four hour cut of the film
taka waititi and chris hemsworth spoke
about the cut to collider where waititi
explained it was about four hours and a
lot of time on set in the moment you're
like this is the greatest thing that
anyone's ever filmed in the history of
filming things and you get into the edit
you're like i still kind of like it and
then after about six months of it being
in the movie you realize it was fun on
the day but it doesn't have any business
being in the movie what kind of things
could we expect to see in a four hour
long thor love and thunder according to
christian bale who plays gore the god
butcher there were two previous mcu
actors who made appearances that wound
up getting cut bale told prince a
scenario
i got to work with peter dinklage that's
not in the final film but i got to work
with him he's fantastic i got to work
with jeff goldblum he's not in the final
film either as you see a lot of stuff
ends up on the cutting room floor even
though it is beautiful brilliant stuff
it's unclear what kind of interactions e
tree and the grand master would have had
with gore but it's a good bet things
wouldn't have shaken out too well for
them thanks to a lawsuit currently in
process we know actress lena heady had a
role that was ultimately cut too she's
never appeared in the mcu before so it's
unclear who she would have played for
our money she would have made an
exceptional hera against russell crowe
zeus one can only hope we'll see all of
these unseen cameos one day it would
make for some great bonus content on
disney plus check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the marvel cinematic
universe are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]